bonjour à tous et bienvenue ici à
l'atelier de métallerie et cofor écouter
comprendre fort mais c'est le principe
ici une école de production c'est assez
original il y en a une vingtaine en
france
bonjour bonjour j'arrive à prendre
différemment c'est un peu le principe
ici
disons qu'ici on part du principe qu'il
faut faire pour bien comprendre et pour
bien apprendre donc en premier lieu on
propose des actions où les jeunes
apprennent en faisant pour des vrais
clients des choses soient dans notre
atelier de métallerie soit de notes dans
notre atelier d'entretien automobile où
on fait pour apprendre mais pourra
prendre un vrai métier pour passer un
diplôme ils sont une douzaine à préparer
le le cap2 de serrurerie métallerie
métal et donc ils sont une douzaine pour
préparer le crp en deux ans ou trois ans
tout dépend de leur expérience à l'école
là où ils en sont en vue ensuite soit
d'intégrer le monde de l'entreprise en
tant que soudeur métallier ou alors soit
pour poursuivre en bac professionnel
soit en bac pro chaudronnerie ouvrage
métallique bâtiment alors il faut dire
que ce sont des jeunes qui ne pourraient
pas intégré au démarrage quand ils
viennent chez vous un cursus différents
ce sont soit des jeunes qui parlent pas
le français soit des jeunes vraiment en
rupture scolaire voilà c'est des jeux de
pour qui la plupart l'école était
difficile une épreuve soit parce que ils
avaient des compétences et leurs
compétences n'ont pas été reconnues soit
parce que pour différentes raisons
sociales familiales etc
l'avis a été difficile pour eux mais
dans les écoles de production les il y a
aussi des jeunes qui font le choix
d'apprendre le métier qu'on propose
et donc on commence à voir des jeunes
qui sont en 3e au collège fait qu'ils
ont envie de préparer ce métier qui vont
venir chez nous il y en à l'année
prochaine y en a dans plein d'autres
écoles de production pour l'instant il y
a deux domaines la métallerie les pneus
et services pourquoi ces domaines là
parce que les écoles de production ont
toujours pour principe de mettre en
place des formations dans des métiers en
tension c'est à dire que les métiers de
la métallerie et de la soudure
il ya une énorme demande un énorme
besoin au niveau des entreprises et au
niveau des pneus et du montage
automobile et de l'entretien automobile
aussi c'est difficile
fidéliser les jeunes qui rentrent en
formation dans ces métiers là alors je
vous abandonne pour aller voir l'étape
la balalaïka eric et ousmane et ricoh
semaine sont en train de travailler à
quelque chose de concret et rémy bonjour
voilà donc on est sur un petit projet
pour un client dont qui demande deux
consoles pour pouvoir suspendre ses
rosiers
oui voilà donc un petit plan après et
des câbles qui seront tendues entre les
deux consoles et ça permettra de relier
ce sens sortie autour des des câbles
alors comment vous avez travaillé avec
ousmane vous avez alors donc le plan il
vient du bureau d'antoine et après on
trace une épure sur le panneau de bois
et de cette épure ou en les cotes les
angles pour pouvoir faire une fiche de
débit pour avoir pour pouvoir quantifier
le nombre de bars qui nous faut tout ça
et ousmane diouf run c'est toi qui a
réalisé tout ça c'est toi qui a fabriqué
oui c'est vrai qu'avec mon maître
professeur éric gestion avec eux
il m'accompagne après aimé montre
comment faire les choses a fait des
réalisations
est-ce que c'est difficile oui c'est un
peu difficile mais avec les rangs quatre
mois et le edge et comprend de mise à
mieux
de quel pays tu viens haussmann moi je
viens de la guinée conakry et tu n'avais
aucune base en métallerie tu connaissais
pas la métallerie avant au nom je
connaissais rien de la métallerie mais
maintenant offrir à mes yeux le japon et
le c ap je crois que ça va être possible
bientôt
oui j'espère avec l'accompagnement de m
professionnels et les professeurs des
cours j'espère savoir ça va bien se
passer
c'est dans combien de temps c'est
l'année prochaine d'un événement bientôt
on te souhaite bonne chance au smad moi
je continue ma petite balade je vais
aller rencontrer d'autres invités un
autre élève qui s'appelle enock et enoch
et bonjour bonjour et il est en
compagnie de son professeur de français
a ni bonjour bonjour il y à une partie
aussi très importante ici c'est
l'apprentissage du français
l'apprentissage des domaines que l'on
passe aussi lors du capc ça oui la
technologie est très importante c'est
une part essentielle pour le métier donc
pour ce qui est du français on a fait le
choix de travailler français en lien
avec avec cette discipline avec le
vocabulaire technique
c'est ce que tu as fait ce matin et nos
quais oui oui tu as appris des mots
quels mots tu as travaillé ce matin avec
annie on a fait le diamètre des passages
et diam été nominé dans mon canapé ses
moteurs et ça c'est compliqué pour toi
parce que tu ne parlais pas français il
y a à combien de temps tu viens d'angola
oui il en france depuis un an et trois
mois et à ce moment là il ne parlait pas
français
et là maintenant ça te semble plus
simple le français oui et le ca paix tu
vas réussir à le passer et bien sûr
écrit oui et bien qu est ce que tu
aimerais à la suite tu voudrais être
dans ces métiers là j'ai dit que c'est
mon projet après mon cher pays
j'aimerais passer un bac professionnel
pour rester dans ce métier risqué en
france oui enfin bon
l'idée c'est ça c'est que chaque jeune
obtiennent un diplôme et surtout un
métier chaque jeune obtenez un mythe un
diplôme et un métier aussi amener les
jeunes à s'interroger sur le sens de la
vie qui veut donner aussi si on les
interroge beaucoup là dessus aussi que
ce qui pour eux est essentielle merci
annie et pour que ces écoles vive
n'oubliez pas ils ont besoin de vos
commandes vous privée comme
professionnelle commandé à l'atelier de
métallerie
merci beaucoup à mes livres